بعد اكتشافها من قبل الاغريق اهتم بدراسه
نسبه الذهبيه علماء وفنانين ومعماريون كفر
منهم ليوناردو دافنشي ومايكل انجلو ومع
الوقت استخدمت النسبه الذهبيه لخلق
التوازن والجمال في لوحات وتمثيل عصر
النهضه في اوروبا ومنها لوحه الموناليزا
وتستخدم النسبه الذهبيه حديثا لقياس مد
مثاليات الوجه وكانت اخر من اعتبرت اجمل
الوجوه حسب النسبه الذهبيه عارضه الازياء
بالحديد فحسب النسبه الذهبيه يتم قياس طول
وعرض لوجه ثم يقسم الطول على العرض ويجب
ان تكون نتيجه بحدود 1.6 ليعتبر الوجه
جميله الهجره اخذ قياسات اقسام الوجه من
خط الشعر الى منطقه العينين ومنطقه
العينين الى اسفل الانف ومن اسفل الانف
الى اسفل الدقن وكل ما كانت القياسات
متقاربه كان الوجه اقرب الى المثاليه ويجب
ان يكون طول الاذن ومساويا لطول الانف وان
يكون مدى العين افقيا ومساويا للمسافه بين
العينين وتتن عمليه قياسها بعد بوجه من
خلال تقنيات رسم قراءه المحسوبه الصوره
المثاليه تتكون عبر مجموعه مقاييس كشفها
الممتلئه والانف اليوناني المستقيم وعظمه
طي الخدود البارذتين